algebra now I asked you to give me a big
favor um when we first started this
topic which we haven't really looked at
yet because we've been sort of working
with numbers and we learn some Wars the
commutator long
yes soceity law and then this morning
that this street distributive law it
gets its divisive two-bit level okay
that's so with all those now all of
those were principles for working with
numbers and how we can sometimes you can
change the order sometimes we can
rewrite the numbers to make it easy to
do it now all of those were trying to
set the stage for this guy I'm not sure
- if you've got the heading Han once you
put an arrow to a draw and I'm going to
give you what my definition of algebra
is because it's on it kind of has a bit
of reputation and the name itself it
actually comes from arabic so it's just
a transitive right - hi age yep ah it's
a I'll tell you about the back story a
little bit later you'll make sense
further on but algebra is all that not
the Manics
when you don't know the numbers now
write that down with me and then I'll
try and explain what I mean okay because
that's all this means all it means we
look this money at how if you have my
feature of five and five times three we
saw I'll come there the same thing and
you can work out what those are we're
gonna look at fractions you can do all
kinds of things to what with them to get
to an answer right but sometimes we were
to solve problems where you don't know
what the numbers actually are but you
still want to work with it okay for
instance I could tell you that I am four
times the age of my daughter plus two
years and I'm also a six times the age
of my son okay now I can tell you that
thanks how you tell you that right you
don't know you don't know how old I am
and you don't know how
my children are evil but on that little
piece of information or activities
information you can work out exactly how
old I am
even though you don't know the numbers
right even when you don't know that
obvious you can still work with them
who's your buddy here maybe you don't
right needle down t27
I said firstly if you think ever there -
I'm not responding to an elf okay if you
think you have it Oh sir I'm not
answering now firstly firstly firstly
algebra is this super power of taking
everything we established already oh you
can add or multiply in any order you
like you can group symbols etc in a in
particular orders with addition biology
and then you can distribute
multiplication etc all those ideas you
can still work with them even when you
don't know what the numbers are because
they're still numbers so they still
follow the same rules there's the first
idea so ad-rock you don't know the
numbers secondly and algebra also gives
us the tools in our office down to
second it gives us the tools to describe
patterns it's it's the language to
describe hands
with any number so I'm going to give you
an example I know there are lots of lots
of Pat's that we can take advantage of
for instance if I give you a list of
numbers right I could say let's see here
um two times zero equals well what's two
times zero
it's just zero okay cool how about
another one how about five times here
what's daddy here
it's still zero how about you bear with
me
how about gave you three times zero
what's that gonna be okay you starting
to get bored of me help right because
what I'd established here is clearly a
pattern you can take any number you like
and multiply by zero and you'll still
get zero so like how can I describe this
how can I succinctly say zero times any
number or any number times zero or still
equal zero so here's a way here's one
way I could write it I could say for
example I could say um a times zero
equals zero for any number hey
so what am I done here right - five
negative three they're numbers but this
guy is like a temporary label right it's
sort of standing in for an actual number
and you can choose any number you like
to be a it's just kind of like what I'm
calling that number of them so I like
this word it's kind of like a label yes
you could just have something you've
noticed is walks hard wait isn't that
what I wrote that yeah you could just
have that one out
yeah well that's true but you see when I
write this it's kind of like well I've
introduced this thing and we usually use
letters like a for making words and
stuff right so I'm kind of repurposing
this label because I'm like I need some
other label I don't want to use one of
my number labels so I'm going to use my
one my alphabetical labels I'm just
going to kind of forward yeah ah now
there's a lot to lots of language and
terminology that we will get to are like
terms is an important one I will get to
it a bit later remember I mean call you
over and over again I've been calling it
a label so far okay it's like a label
for this other number okay so a more
technical name for this which I'm going
to just say oh no it starts with a Pete
more technical name for this label you
know to get a printable
okay so pro anymore this is a pretty
room pronumeral literally means it's not
of you rule a is not a new rule it's a
letter but it's standing in for a
numeral it's just kind of like
temporarily saying hey guys I act just
like a number I can be actually any
number you like and I'll still be true
you take any know about my mother's do
it you'll still get 0 okay you'll see
this language of pronumerals you can
also see another word which starts with
me called a variable okay now I'm not
going to tell you this time so I'm going
to ask you why do you think it's called
a variable for why could we use this
thing yeah Kimmy yeah like very just
means change doesn't it right and so he
are a I can change it to be too I can
change it to 583 and it's still true it
still makes sense okay so this idea here
of being able to describe patterns that
refer any number or to be able to talk
about numbers when you don't know what
the numbers are that's all algebra is
it's not scary it's actually a really
simple idea we do all the time I can say
to you okay I know that there are at the
moment there are 56 miles
see sighs when I get that number 56
problem yeah John can of the people in
the class and then you climbs the like
that number
yeah very good so I said and you might
actually I'd love you to write this with
me right I said eyes equals eye two
times the number of people so I can
actually because as you've seen
mathematicians famously lazy right so
we're like this takes so long to write
why don't abbreviate this with some
labels with some pretty rules right I
could say e equals 2 times P I should
have a time sign of it okay I'll talk
about the abbreviations in a second yeah
don't you not have to write the time
yeah I will talk about that in a second
but I'll establish the language here
right so again here these two things are
numbers which I don't necessarily know I
happened to count all of us who came in
and then I added it would be okay so
that's how I knew people were in the
room but you know what this this is a
pattern that's true for any number if I
assuming everyone's got two eyes okay I
can go into the next classroom and if
there are word yeah oh I lose their eyes
and that kind of thing but if I go into
a classroom in them like there are 31
people here 31 people then you don't
have to go secondarily ateke one two
three four five you know if you count
all of those there's a pattern here I
can take advantage off and you can just
say 62 eyes does that make sense